uh i have been playing a lot of golf
yes it is um completely taken over my
life
and i mean with kovid the golf courses
got shut down for a while
and then when they opened back up it was
like well this is all that we can do
anyway so
i need to get outside the house i need
some sanity
i need an escape and golf is the perfect
tool
yeah um how have you been skewing
towards less bogeys
more birdies uh definitely bogeys are
outweighing the birdies
absolutely uh there was i was starting
to get okay and then you know you try to
switch something with the swing and then
all of a sudden
you revert back to uh a higher handicap
than you had gotten down to so i i'm
i'm in and out of of pars and bogies and
a run of devils you never know i
i i suck at golf like i mean i i play a
little bit i'm a member out i live in
scottsdale
and i'm a member at a course called
scottsdale national out here
so i get out like twice a year um which
i think i'm the perfect member for them
i think there's about 10 people a day
out there so if you're
ever looking for a course that has um
very low activity
but two courses and a par three nine
hole course
uh and two club houses then scottsdale
nationals for you
it sounds perfect that sounds like my
pace of golf
my level of activity perfect yeah and
there's like it's a fun place to go
because there's no rules
meaning like out here there's a place
called whisper rock have you ever played
at whisper rock
no no um it's a fancy place out here and
you know you can't and there's other
another one called estancia and
like you can't use your phone you can't
wear your ray
you know what at one of them like women
can't go most of the time and
um but at scottsdale national it's like
headlights
turn your music up and yeah um you know
talk on your phone wear your hat have a
good time so
that's what buggy boys is all about oh
well tell me
why do you have a why do you have a
clothing line
i mean design and fashion in general has
always been
a passion of mine i think that um you
know if i wasn't
into music i'd probably do something in
the design world
we've always done our own graphics our
own merch
our own album covers music videos so
that part of it's always been entrenched
in the music that we that we've done and
um it was just kind of a natural
progression i got tired of designing
t-shirts with
my name on them that i'm like i just
can't wear this there's no way that i'm
gonna pull this off ever
um nor want to so it was definitely a
you know a moment when i started playing
golf and i walked into
you know the pro shops and i'd be like i
just am not inspired by any of this
clothing like this is not interesting to
me
and um i wanted to create something that
stood out that was a little bit
different
a little bit left field yet also paid
homage to
uh era that was before my time where
people actually
had style on the golf course you know
people really
you have your arnold palmer's and you're
paying stewards and your lee trivinos
and
chichi rodriguez guys that really um
looked fantastic i'm like that
is what where we need to take this game
we need to diversify this game it needs
to be more fun we need to be
make sure that whoever has wants a set
of clubs can get one
that we get the youth out there that we
really switch it up and kind of
shift this narrative of this white
stodgy elite exclusive club that
golf has been for so long that's i mean
that's true
but yet i do feel like there's like an
air of
um kind of like i'm thinking it's almost
like a play on thrift shop like there's
like a play on like
old school like the plaids and like
almost like grandfather you're talking
about like the older players and like
they are grandfathers now
so i did that is that is that it all
like part of the sort of
i don't know not mindset but the uh the
design
or the vibe completely i mean i was
dressing up
in old golf outfits before i
ever even thought of picking up a club i
mean this was this dates back to me
being in like
high school i mean this is where this is
where thrift shop came from was like me
going
into thrift shops getting out the
craziest plaid outfits that i possibly
could
and um and whatever else i could find
putting those clothes together making an
outfit that i couldn't go by
you know wherever department store
and and going out and having fun and i
think i just transferred that
into the actual game of golf when i
picked it up and i was like i just i
enjoy
i feel like i play better in a pair of
plaid pants
i just do i just play better both
there's something about it